peu
[Musique]
février 1828 dans une petite île battue
par les vents
mais un écrivain dont l'oeuvre
extraordinaire traduite en plus de cent
seize langues restent encore aujourd'hui
celle qui est le plus lu dans le monde
entier
il s'appelait jules verne avril 1926 un
écrivain américain décide de créer une
revue dans laquelle il publiera des
textes de prophétie scientifique dit il
les communes et guère satisfait de ce
terme
il va en créer un autre qui fera
littéralement fortune science-fiction
avril 1979 pour la première fois en
europe et créer un magazine de
télévision entièrement consacrée à la
science fiction temps x eh bien oui
temps x et donc votre magazine le
magazine de tous ceux qui aiment et
connaissent la science fiction bien sûr
mais également de tous ceux qui
s'intéressant à l'avenir souhaitant
découvrir certains aspects que sera
notre monde demain telle est la question
que se posent les heures de science
fiction et c'est de cette réponse que
découle toute la science fiction c'est à
dire une approche du futur par la voix
de l'imaginaire et avant tout par la
voie du roman depuis jules verne tenez
vous bien plus de cinquante mille textes
ont été publiés
et puis il ya bien sûr le cinéma qui n'a
pas entendu parler ou vu des films comme
rencontre du troisième type ou encore la
guerre des étoiles
et puis il ya encore la bande dessinée
la musique le cinéma le théâtre même la
sculpture de science fiction
bref on peut dire aujourd'hui que la
science fiction est bel et bien partout
alors partons à la découverte à la
découverte de ce nouveau et passionnant
domaine de la culture où tout est
possible et avant tout commençons par
l'actualité
chaque semaine nous vous présenterons
des informations des films des ouvrages
que nous sélectionnerons exprès pour
vous et qui nous paraîtront les plus
intéressants d'autre part dans leurs
rubriques temps x à la une
nous mettrons en valeur chaque fois un
événement particulièrement important
dans le champ de la science fiction
il pourra s'agir bien sûr d'ouvragé il
pourrait s'agir également de tout autre
chose
alan de temps x cette semaine andré
ruellan l'auteur de science fiction bien
connu et enfin pour tous ceux qui
veulent rêver au futur eh bien eh bien
nous ferons une découverte des grands
thèmes de science fiction
et cette fois-ci nous commencerons
par le voyage dans l'espace que nous
mettrons en question tout à l'heure en
compagnie du physicien jean pierre petit
voilà c'est comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure à un voyage que nous vous
invitons à un fabuleux voyage qui nous
mènera très loin jusqu'aux frontières du
possible
alors attention nous ne sommes plus en
1979 temps x vous souhaite la bienvenue
dans l'avenir imaginons qu'ils nous
sommes aussi de voyager dans l'espace
les douars l'étoile jusqu'aux confins de
l'univers et d'y rencontrer des
civilisations extraterrestres
cette note les autres imaginons aussi
nous soyons secondes et dans toutes nos
tâches par des robots et que des
cerveaux électronique l'incroyable
puissance résonne notre place les
problèmes les plus complexes
imaginons enfin que nous ayons maîtriser
le problème du vieillissement et de la
main que nous ayons aussi développé en
eu des super pouvoirs qui ferait de nous
ce qu'on appelle des sur an
tout cela aujourd'hui c'est encore de la
science fiction mais c'est aussi
peut-être la réalité de gueule et je
voudrais maintenant m'adresser à un
jeune invité il a 13 ans il s'appelle
frédéric il est
je crois fanatiques de science fiction
inédits depuis cinq ans j'aimerais tout
de suite puisque tu as lu le livre dans
le virulent que tu me donnes ton opinion
sur cet ouvrage est ce que c'est de la
science fiction pour toi ben à mon avis
c'est la fosse entre la science-fiction
à une sorte de fantastique étrange parce
que la frontière oui c'est la frontière
c'est la limite pourquoi ce que tu lis
de la science-fiction toi qui es jeunes
ménages et la science fiction parce qu'à
mon avis un auteur de science-fiction un
champ un terrain d'expression beaucoup
plus vaste qu'un autre il peut créer des
situations qu'on ne trouve pas dans
d'autres romans et en plus la science
fiction on m'apporte aussi une évasion
une distraction très grande
j'aimerais que tu me dises ce que ta
définition de la science fiction et
fabrique ma définition de la science
fiction c'est une recherche prospective
du possible
oulala ça c'est formidable écoutez je
vous remercie l'un et l'autre je
rappelle donc le titre du livre à la une
cette semaine les chiens d'andré ruellan
aux éditions lattès
un livre auquel évidemment temps x
souhaitent de nombreux lecteurs
lors de naviguer à placer sous sous
hypnose préparatoire le sujet et nous
allons assister en direct
nous allons donc assister en direct à
une transe hypnotique au cours de
laquelle jean pierre prévôt va comme il
l'a fait de nombreuses reprises raconter
son aventure et peut-être préciser la
nature de son contact
alors daniel buguet si vous êtes prêts
nous pourrions procéder peut-être à la
séance de façon à ce que nous puissions
établir un dialogue avec avec jean
pierre est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
je pense qu'il est prêt essayez vous
même
tu dors toujours très profondément qui
coûtent toujours le son de la voix du
secteur dont donc tomberait et
insensible absolument authentiques de
totalement insensible le public et en
importe qu un simple qu'il ressent
absolument aucune douleur
absolument aucune douleur absolument
aucune nouvelle j'ai toujours très bien
très calme et très en vue qui dort
profondément très profondément pourtant
ma voix qui entend toujours le son de ma
voix tu n'entends que ma voiture beckham
à droite il te réveilleras que lorsque
je te rencontrer l'ordre et constant tu
dors très très bien très calme et très
détendu
tu vas te de transporter tout être
emporté dans le temps lors d'une
rencontre avec orgueilleux de la
remontée dans le temps tu remontes
et tu vas aller dans le temps un jour où
j'ai rencontré alors qu'il a un jour où
tu as pu poser des questions et total
heureuse que je poserais des questions
tu pourra répondre tout à fait
clairement santé nous voir sont
infondées est-ce que tu prends mon temps
c'est très bien est ce que tu es arrivé
en jour d'une rencontre avec tu veux
parler un peu plus fort tu peux parler
tout à fait normalement et un petit peu
plus fort afin que tout le monde
l'entende de ce que tu as à thiais est
ce que tu as à dire oui c'est très bien
alors maintenant tu vas par exemple plus
demander d'où il vient
tu peux lui demander d'en deviens tu
sais que tu es comme dans un rêve
exactement comme nazaire et tu peux
dialoguer avec lui alors à partir de
maintenant au travers des questions que
je fait opposés et que tu vas lui poser
tu vas nous donner sa réponse est ce que
ce produit nous demander d'oublier
tu peux nous donner la réponse
m'expliquer de l'espace je suis jamais
sur la provenance
si jamais c'est l'endroit exact tu es en
face de lui repas jeux les cas la
question pour voir mais jamais fournir
la réponse bien
qu'est ce qu'il est puisque sa tirade où
est le lien qui les unit
un habitant du une autre planète hors de
la galaxie
une audition devant d'une autre planète
c'est la galaxie et qu'est ce qu'il dit
est ce que patrick plusieurs plusieurs
choses mais on trouve d'abord nous nous
montrer que depuis des années on élus
les moutons d'une science des faussaires
dans les moyens de les rencontrer
officiellement et non plus par heather
[Musique]
pour tendre une perche pour éviter un
long retour de 80 euros
[Musique]
est-ce qu'ils pourraient être
communiqués à le message spécial oso
fait déjà communiqué je l'avais japonais
elle est aussi vieux d'année vidéo
ramène à l'état de veille tout en pierre
prévost je voudrais que vous tiriez une
conclusion de ceux ci selon vous donc
qu'il existe un savoir message je viens
de se rejouer deux choses d'abord la
notion de rendez-vous de 1983 le point
de non retour et 1995 1992 de quoi
s'agit-il
horrillo ce personnage l'entité dont qui
est en contact avec des têtes qui est
charnelle n'est ce pas que jean qu'une
jean pierre prévôt rencontré plusieurs
fois qui a été l'illustration apparu
dans le virage mais nous avons un studio
ici une illustration de sa bile mangin
qu'il représente mais l'autre façon
photographique
toutefois c'est peut-être cette entité
je crois qu'il est un être cher comme
vous et moi donne un message ne donne
pas d'ordre
il s'agit pour nous les terrienne de
prendre conscience du fait que si nous
continuons à faire les imbéciles je dis
un mot c'est humain féminisme tel que
nous le faisons en polluant la terre en
essayant de nous entretuer les uns les
autres nous courrons avec la strophe
et attention je ne voudrais pas que nos
amis qu'une regarde se méprenne nous ne
sommes pas porteur de messages notre
prophète et autres pas du tout mais
parce qu'il ya un délai ou d'une
religion d'une secte vous me n'y aurait
pas qu'il y a beaucoup de mouvements
maintenant six ans qui se prévalent de
contact avec des extraterrestre c'est
vraiment là la secte merelle les qui ont
un certain nombre de messages a délivré
est ce que on est en face l'une d'une
chose de ce type ou est-ce que ces
différences alors vous
ces différents mais tous les messages
que reçoivent les contacts et ont ceci
de commun c'est qu'ils prêchent l'amour
des êtres les uns envers les autres
ils prêchent la fraternité vous allez me
dire qu'un bravo il ya 2000 ans a fait
la même chose et qu'il a mal fini
je le sais le savons tous mais
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on prêche le besoin
de fraternité
lorsqu'on dit tendez nous la main et
nous vous tendez peu plus le point de
s'amener sourire et on dit mais qu'est
ce que c'est si soir là ce sont des
leçons des sectateurs ce sont des gens
qui vont faire un culte et soeurs mais
pas du tout lors comment de que
risquons-nous nous terriens à prêcher la
fraternité a essayé de me serrer la main
mais nous avons tout à gagner c'est le
pari de pascal éperlans nous gagné 6 me
continue à pourrir la terre nous avions
ces êtres
jadis on fait de la terre ou du moins on
décide à en faire une sorte de paradis
c'est de cette notion de là que vient
cette notion dédain et nous l'avons
transformé en porcherie
on peut pas à vivre continent dans une
poche c'est donc le sens du message de
l'entité orio contacté j'ai retenu donc
une date qui est le 15 août 1980 une
date qui est en harmonie d'ailleurs avec
le calendrier chrétien puisque le 15
août est une date très importante dans
ce calendrier je crois que nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir en détail sur
cette affaire et simplement posé une
question à jean pierre prévôt qui
maintenant est de nouveau à l'état de
veille qui pourra donc parler
normalement
tout à l'heure ils étaient en hypnose
maintenant il est comme nous tous et
jean-pierre est-ce que vous avez la
conviction que ce rendez vous du 15 août
1980 est le véritable rendez vous celui
qui fera la décision rapidement très
rapidement
honnêtement je sais pas honnêtement j'ai
une confiance aveugle dans tout ce qui
m'a été dit pascal entreprises nous ont
fait démonstration que c'était véridique
en plus j'ai une confiance aveugle parce
que ces gens-là à ces êtres qui nous
apporte comme disait jamie la
possibilité de se sortir de la situation
dans laquelle on est il pourrait très
bien nous laisser tel qu'on est donc
puisqu'ils viennent nous aider il n'y a
pas de raison pour leur faire confiance
et je pense pas que s'ils ont avancé une
doute une date si proche de nous
puisqu'elle au mois d'août de cette
année je pense pas que ce soit pour
faire une blague bien c'est avec
d'humilité que nous vous faisons
confiance et que nous demandons ce que
l'ensemble de ceux qui nous écoutent
maintenant face ce bulletin de confiance
nous pouvons essayer de répondre à cette
question nous tournant vers l'homme du
xxième siècle docteur salomon ce sera
notre dernière question comment
envisagez-vous le visage donc de cet
homme du 21e siècle avec beaucoup
d'optimisme mais avec un optimisme très
vite parce que ça ne se vend pas sans
mal par les révolutions je crois pas à
une apocalypse nucléaire mais il y aura
beaucoup de bouleversements
mais l'homme du xxième siècle sera amené
à une certaine convivialité parce que la
planète est tout petit
parce que les ressources s'épuisent et
parce que ce selon dd fameuse expérience
sur la densité des poissons dans un
bocal n'avons pas le temps d'en parler
ici à partir d'un certain seuil
une certaine coexistence établi on passe
de la de la planète telle qu'elle est à
la planète bateau il faut délimiter
l'espace et acquérir un nouveau code de
conduite
ce nouveau code de conduite nous sommes
très reconnaissants de par bien voulu
l'exquis c'est avec nous et puis vous
pourrez vous qui se vous y intéressez
essayé d'en savoir plus dans cet ouvrage
absolument passionnant que le docteur
salomon donc a publié sous le titre
l'avenir de la vie et vous pourrez y
voir particulier que il y est question
de l'avenir de la vie dans l'espace car
l'espace représente évidemment et
peut-être même le milieu privilégié pour
un développement futur
la vie car en fait et 1985 des hommes
travailleront en permanence dans
l'espace et ils vivront des périodes
assez longues
et puis à partir du début du xxième
siècle des bases permanentes seront
installés soit autour de la terre soit
sur d'autres mondes dans le système
solaire
et tout ceci permettra à l'homme de
pénétrer un milieu nouveau mais un
milieu qui est quand même extrêmement
hostile pas de pesanteur des
températures inférieures à 270 degrés en
dessous de zéro
pas de limites physiques tangibles et
ceci évidemment étant ajouté sur ajouter
par le fait qu'il y à des agresseurs
extrêmement nombreux dans ce milieu tout
d'abord des rayons cosmiques dont
certains sont extrêmement dangereux et
puis également des gars stellaire de
toute nature et enfin des poussières
dans certaines contiennent des micro
organismes des particules organiques
pour se protéger contre ce milieu
l'homme devra effectivement inventé un
certain nombre de barrières ce sera la
médecine spatiale de le faire des
barrières qui le protégeront sur le plan
physique également sur le plan psychique
et peut-être même devra-t-il être
modifié dans sa structure biologique qui
sait
[Musique]